do you guys since we have the right to
choose what to do with our bodies do
would you support men having the right
to have a financial abortion
oh yeah 100 you would support that yeah
yeah yeah yeah
no
no if they slept with you yeah i just i
didn't say my point beforehand but i
think if you both had sex at the end of
the day you've had sex what can happen
if you have sex you can have a child
therefore you automatically have gone
into that agreement if the child is now
born you both have financial
responsibilities
so then are you pro-life like do you not
believe in abortion
me personally it's not that i don't
believe in abortion um if someone wants
to get an abortion that's prerogative go
for it go do what you please me
personally no i don't believe but you're
you're you support people like women
having the right to if they want to yeah
so so wouldn't you think since we have
the right to not be a mother they should
have the right not to be a father
because like if if i get pregnant by a
guy right i i can tomorrow say i don't
want to be a mom get an abortion up to
six months in but he he's stuck paying
child support for 18 years
they created avenues for women to get
out of it they didn't create them for
men but it was men really like
you lot could have your tubes hide men
could you could have tubes tied yeah
that's permanent no no no no
it can be reversed
women
can't
like so you lot could actually
physically have it done and then choose
when you want to have kids then have
them undone but we have
we have an iud you could get an iud and
you're chilling
oh yeah sorry we call it okay but those
things i mean i don't know for a man
what the effects are because they don't
really do it but for a woman there's a
lot of things that happen to our bodies
when we take when we put the coil in
when we take the pill like me personally
i cannot take the pill like it it does a
lot to me inside and it
it tells me what so i just have to you
know i just don't have sex it's the best
kind of conception and but
like for a man they can get their tubes
tied and you know why is society not
saying let's tile the men's tubes and
then when you want to have a kid
they are they are if you've seen the
media around bro versus wade
they're literally telling men to get
vasectomies but they're not always
reversible and that's a pretty big risk
yeah so so what i'm saying is for the
woman we have
we have abortion that's one form of
birth control we have plan b that's
another form of birth control we have
the pill we have an iud we can get that
thingy in her arm i don't know what it's
called
yeah
we can
do adoption if we want to have the kib
and give it up for adoption but i mean
all of those
carry a significant risk the same way in
which a vasectomy would to a man right
but why was nothing developed for a man
it's what my question is actually it
actually was no it actually was well but
it wasn't marketed because they thought
it wasn't gonna no i think men wouldn't
want to
most men would
you're right and also the thing is what
you have to remember is that when it
comes to um who you're going to market
let's say you're a pharmaceutical
company you're going to market a drug to
someone right obviously the who does the
greater risk come from women well what
i'm saying is is those drugs are not
readily available for men they don't
have that option no women because of the
pharmaceutical right but that's not
men's that's not men in general's fault
okay okay but that's a small percentage
of men that's not that's not the
majority of everyday joe schmoe that's
just having sex i still think men have
way this and listen this is i think this
is a really big point men who have way
more problems with doctors pills stuff
like that than women do
well then you think we would have less
unplanned pregnancies on the women's
side and they take birth control but
they do take well a lot of women do take
birth control
okay
oh well all my friends do
to their own detriment i know but then
why do we have so many single parent
homes
well yeah but i think i think that's an
er that's an inevitability no no it's
not it's not an inevitability
when you have the choice to get an iud
and you have a 99.99 chance of not
getting pregnant
so so what my point my point is that
like women we have all the power when it
comes to reproduction we choose who gets
born the men have no say in this
absolutely none because at the end of
the day i can get an abortion and the
men have don't have a say that they can
put a condom on yeah they could that's
it but okay good that's the only thing
yeah i know but you could do it you can
still do it but here's the thing the
condom could break and the nba issued
statements saying that women are
stealing condoms yeah so okay so so what
i'm saying is a guy can do every single
thing right he can do it guys are also
taking off the condom during set like we
actually had it recently so broken women
women can also be on
any type of birth control and still get
pregnant yeah but that's the exception
it's not the rule it's a 99.99 percent
or nine five or so it's it's something
stupid because the thing is we're
talking about why if um if a guy's
condoms break can't yeah
look we're talking about but but you
we're talking she could still steal it
like the whole point is
the point is that you have
legally it incentivizes women to try to
get kids off of rich men
and there's whole reddit threads of
women trying to get pregnant by their
boyfriends telling him let me finish
there's whole thread at threads women
trying to get pregnant by their
boyfriends
and
like like why are we in a society that
allows this where men have no rights
when it comes to reproduction
you were talking about the exception to
the rule right
um i don't think
that's the rule i don't think women
by and large are going out there taking
the condos off men because they're
desperate to have babies brittany renner
made a whole video teaching she was
famous off
i think i think we even though you're
saying this um
a lot why would the nba issue a
statement
because if that's what's going on to a
small percentage of men in society what
is going on with the average joe but
they do allow it because you do allow a
woman to i i there was a guy used to see
and
he's a lovely guy still friends to this
day he you know when we finished he used
to literally take it off tie it up and
take it home
he would leave with it and i asked him
one day i was like how comes you know
he's like you know he's like my mom
taught me to take it home oh to make
sure that doesn't happen yeah but he's
actively doing stuff and there's a lot
of men that don't actively even look at
others don't know but he shouldn't have
yeah but
he shouldn't have to do that
so my point is even even if you get
pregnant right
you have a right to not be a mother why
doesn't he get a right not to be a
father
so so babies babies coming you can you
can get an abortion or you can keep it
but then don't sleep with don't sleep
with her if you don't have the intention
of like don't sleep with him yeah it's
true because because i could use the
same argument that pro-life people use
people i'm not saying that you're wrong
about women i'm just saying it works
both ways if you don't want to have a
baby with somebody don't sleep with them
if there's a chance that the condom's
not going to work or she's going to get
pregnant don't do it same with the woman
but don't do it
right but then shouldn't should it then
wouldn't you say you'd be pro-life then
what because i'm saying don't do it yeah
because that's the same argument so then
don't don't sleep with him don't you
can't get an abortion i'm not saying you
deal with the consequences i'm not
saying you can't get an abortion i'm not
saying you have to deal with the
consequences but you both have a choice
everyone has a choice but except for
that always put yeah it's always put
there's there's no choice for the man
don't sleep if i know but don't sleep
with him yeah it's true so i'm saying if
you if she's pregnant the baby's already
coming she has a choice he doesn't why
is that fair every single pregnancy
isn't a choice which is why
things like well it is true because
sometimes
everything isn't all roasted are you
talking about are you talking about
grape is that what you're talking about
that's that's less than one percent of
abortions
for statistics so so it's from the
abortion clinic
okay do you have a different statistic
that you brought so or is this just
based on what you feel but okay okay so
it's based off of what it's based off of
what you feel so forty percent of women
that get abortions have had two or more
abortions
so it seems like you don't know what
their abortions are from yeah you know
that they're from grape because they're
surveys they don't want it they want to
go on the topic
they're surveyed and it's less than one
percent you're speaking as if it's
absolute fact you know why every single
person has one okay but you're you're
speaking as if you have any data at all
what they are
or google to tell me what is right when
i have friends and i have people and i
know a lot of women
and yeah someone can go and do public
interviews whether you have a mic or not
you speak to people every day and you
get data from them so i speak to more
people than anyone in this room i have
women
you don't think having a live show four
times a week interviewing people on the
street but i'm just saying you're saying
that everyone pregnancy is like no my
choice is not no i'm i'm saying that
less than i'm saying that less than one
percent of pregnancies are in the
instances of grape do you think the
majority of men are out here grapeing
women is that your opinion every single
person that's been graped wants to do a
yeah yeah but here's here's just like
there's everyone in your own happy
marriage doesn't want to exactly they
don't want to sit there okay okay let's
triple it let's triple it let's triple
it let's triple it it's still only three
percent even if you tripled it i don't
even think it would be that high
i don't think so because but this is all
based on your feelings this is all based
on your feelings there's no facts in it
google search statistics
is that unfortunately as much as facts
play a part so do feelings emotion and
facts do actually have a hand in each
other because the thing is that is that
statistics can only tell you one side of
something feelings can also tell you
another side okay it doesn't mean one or
the other is completely correct okay so
so this is how they gather the data they
survey people at different abortion
clinics in the u.s this is this is a us
statistic and you can also look on the
uk government website too and it's
similar so if you're looking at
different countries different abortion
clinics in different states and
different countries you and it's all
saying the same thing you don't think
that indicates that maybe that's the
that's the rate
i i i think i think once again i think
again
or is it based on how you you feel you
can't you can't study study study study
study so for example a lot of people
don't know what's happening right so for
example i know a lot of women and i've
certainly been in that position before
myself who have not actually realized
they've been raped because say grapes so
great oh sorry grapes
because we
sometimes i think have you not realized
you've been great well because there's
because there's massive gray areas there
with coercion and manipulation
and i just think that the reality of it
is is that sometimes um
you know you can get pushed into a
situation which you didn't really want
to be in and i think that that can
sometimes be put i'm not saying all that
it's a nuanced conversation we can't
speak on every single individual case
but as a whole i think there are a lot
of women who might have
right might have not said no but not
said yes not wanted it and
later if they didn't say no how how is
he supposed to know that well okay
can i just say something sorry i have to
get involved because this is something
that's happened to me so
there is a
it happened to me
and i didn't know i thought i'd got
drunk and i was just like oh it's okay i
hadn't i'd been drugged and i had no
idea right like and i woke up the next
morning thinking oh my god like i did
this and why would i do this but it's
because i'd been drugged well if you
were drugged then that's clearly great
yeah but i didn't know i didn't know at
first so i'll tell you what happened and
people probably think i'm stupid like i
said i didn't know what had happened to
me i thought i drank a lot
and that i'd put myself in this position
which is really really bad like why for
yourself decisions first time i'm
talking about this by the way
i then um
i went out with a person again
and the same thing happened the exact
same thing happened to me and obviously
this time i went and you know because i
was like how on earth did it happen
again
and i didn't know so there is instances
where you don't know
you don't know what's happened to you
because a lot of women won't go and get
checked out afterwards to make sure
would you would you would you would you
would you agree that that's the
exception it's not the rule
because i think a lot of men are doing
that men
so that you're is that your opinion on
man that the majority of men are out
here grapeing women i think it happens a
lot i think it does happen a lot i think
a lot more women have been great
than will ever come out because a lot
more women won't they won't say they
don't talk about it like i said i
i
haven't gone and put lay down a
statement because i don't want to yeah
like i i don't want it for myself and
there's a lot of women out there that
feel the same they won't they don't want
to do it so those statistics will never
show because they've never said it have
you ever do
do you know i'm assuming you do that um
the actual convictions that go through
for rape are incredibly great great
great are incredibly low
yeah incredibly low oh yeah but you
don't know if every girl that's accusing
someone is telling the truth no of
course you don't so so it it should be
difficult to convict somebody i think it
should be i think it should be difficult
in certain certain circumstances but i
mean i i saw a
television program once where they were
following police and they got to
i mean
if this woman was lying
i would be shocked she was in absolute
bits and and the guy even admitted to a
raping great broker raping her
on tv he admitted it on tv and then he
went in he changed his statement later
he
i don't i don't know that individual
story but
but it's like this this narrative that
all men are graping women i i think is
harmful to men and i think we're again
we're looking at exceptions rather than
the rule i didn't say
and so
but even even a lot i think that's
harmful that's why we're in the place
that we are today it's so easy for a
woman to lie yeah
and so that's that's why it's important
to have a really it's it needs to be
hard to convict someone look what
happened with amber hurt and johnny depp
women abuse that power
i mean again i think our person my
personal opinion on that is that that's
an incredibly isolated uh no because
that's a man with money status and power
so if that happened to someone that's if
that if that happened to someone that's
famous what does that say about the
average man who didn't have money status
or power any way to protect himself or
defend himself right but i think that
that's one of those relationships you
were talking about mutually abusive i
don't think it was johnny being more
abusive to her or her being more either
yeah but he they interviewed all of his
exes he never hit any of them well
yes
yeah
yeah
okay but they've still been there this
was a really public trial yeah no i know
there was but there's there were still
incidences during johnny depp's career
where he's been seen to be violent
no
no
that's just the narrative they're trying
to spin and like this is how clearly it
works because
we're laying out the facts and then
you're going off what you're feeling and
mix it in with the with the actual
reality of the situation and this is
often what happened and like this is an
argument tactic guys like it's it's
literally when you don't have facts
numbers or statistics you bring out
extreme scenarios when it's not the
rules sorry how was i bringing out on
the street so so we were talking about
assault earlier when we were talking
about roe versus wade yeah and so so you
guys were saying it's less than one
percent of and you guys were saying that
it's more prevalent than it is
when that's that's the extreme i just
replied to what was said you said that
no i'm talking about okay yeah i i'm
still i'm confused as to what exact
point you're bringing out okay well we
you can watch it back later no no but
but my point is that it's like we're
talking about one thing and when we talk
about one topic we go off topic because
we're bringing up extreme situations
when we're talking about in general
well my personal opinion i i i get what
you're saying but on the same token i
think that there are a lot of different
reasons
why something happens in one sphere and
so sometimes bringing up a a point from
somewhere else actually
links in to what we're talking about
that's
that's what i've learned from
my life right but i'm saying exceptions
don't make the rule
i i i think what what rule are we
talking about here i i don't think we
were talking about roe versus no no no i
know then and then you guys brought up
what i mean is when you say the rule is
the rule is that women use abortion as a
form of birth control rather than
something that should be used in in an
extreme circumstance right so so again
40 of women that that have abortions
have already had two or more they don't
track the 60 to see if they have more in
the future
okay and a lot of people make it an
income and an education type of issue
but only eight percent of women below
the poverty line actually get abortions
where one out of three women over that
make over 47 thousand dollars per year
getting abortion right okay all right i
didn't know that
okay
i'm gonna